[Musique]
barbara
ravi qui frôle donc la victoire la
chanteuse qui a été félicité sur twitter
par le président dary emmanuel macron
qui a tweeté à 00h50 précisément un
grand bravo et merci de réaliser sera
fou d'une petite fille aux yeux noirs
jouffroy mais je vais faire attention de
ne pas me pencher pendant là pendant les
matches la nation parce que je sais pas
lequel des trois serait ensuite coupable
de non observation d'une victoire
entachée par une vive polémique sur les
réseaux sociaux en cause cette vidéo
filmée au cours de la soirée
le groupe dément avoir consommé de la
drogue en plein direct
je sais pas si c'est une mauvaise blague
ou s'il est en train de sniffer soyons
clairs j'espère hip hop voilà j'attends
d'avoir des explications
l'eurovision à la responsabilité de
l'honneur de ce concours
mais s'il ya besoin de faire des tests
ils font les tests les gens pensent que
vous prenez de la coupe c'était quoi
c'est thomas cassé un verre cassé je ne
prends pas de broc s'il vous plaît quand
demande que tout oppose se rencontrent
bonjour comment va commenter vous même
ambiance décontractée entre le président
et les deux youtuber dès le début de la
vidéo vous faites pas ça mes mouchoirs
souvent sur mes aisselles
kylie ann m bape et c'est moi qui
m'occupe de sa carrière et donc qu'il y
en ait mbappé va quitter le psg dans les
prochaines semaines pour l'olympique de
marseille
quel est le risque mais parce que vous
vous sortez des codes des discours
convenus laisser ya pas il ya une forme
de deux voies d'un confort qui peut être
apportée par
de la manière dont les questions sont
posées les thèmes qui sont abordés les
les anecdotes qu'il faut raconter ce
serait un des transferts les plus
énormes roues
ce serait le plus gros concert puis le
mérite c'est quand fonctionne pas c'est
que si l'objectif c'est d'amuser c'est
le destin de la france qui est en jeu
et moi je n'ai jamais considéré les
jeunes comme des comme des demeurés pas
du tout cela vous choque c'est pas que
ça me choque c'est que ça n'a aucun
intérêt c c'est une tentative désespérée
d'un président de la république a échoué
pour faire diversion
il y annonçait la nouvelle à nos amis à
savoir que vous aviez quitté le psg pour
l'olympique de marseille n'en faites pas
trop non plus qu est d'abord je constate
que emmanuel macron et et meilleur
youtuber que président de la république
moi j'ai un seul souci concernant la
jeunesse aujourd'hui on a des milliers
de jeunes qui passent des bancs de la
fac au fil d aide alimentaire du secours
populaire ou des restos du coeur
la seule question à laquelle doit
répondre le président de la réunion
n'est c'est comment on peut accepter ça
chacun aura donc un gage le président
devra afficher la photo des deux
youtuber lors de sa prise de parole le
jour de la fête nationale le 14 juillet
eux prendront place dans l'un des avions
de la patrouille de france
moi je regarde le bilan de maquereaux je
me moque de savoir comment ils
communiquent
voilà le bilan de monsieur macron pour
moi les français l'ont compris
après il peut l'expliquer il peut
l'expliquer sur tik tok youtube ou je ne
sais quoi je pense que les français
l'ont jugé je trouve normal que dans la
période de crise sanitaire majeure que
nous traversions le président de la
république incite les youtuber à prendre
ce sujet à bras le corps et diffuser des
messages permettant aux jeunes rien
faire vous ce genre d'exercices avec des
youtube heures bob peut-être que je leur
ai fermé une partie des deux millions
d'habitants de goma quittent leur ville
souvent à pied sous un ciel rouge et
dans une odeur de soufre
la vidéo de 36 minutes se termine par un
concert du groupe
de métal ultra vomit dans le jardin de
l'elysée
[Musique]
une coulée de lave du volcan nyiragongo
descend sur la ville située à l'est du
congo aéroports et habitations sont
touchés l'électricité a été coupée dans
certains quartiers alors bientôt la
vidéo de jean yves le drian peut-être
avec mc fly & carry tôt